Fox in the hound - here we go this is
yet another film that you think of when
you think ooh
crappy direct-to-dvd Disney sequel once
again going back to my original Disney
cember review of Fox and the Hound I
thought it was good no not great but it
had some substance there it was kind of
cute seep in the same way Bambi was
cutesy and it needed to be and it kind
of tricked kids into thinking it's a
light and fluffy story when suddenly
whoa it's like a really heavy and dark
story but unlike Bambi tuit actually
tried to keep that same spirit Fox in
the Hound to is just an obvious cash-in
that doesn't try at all well for the
most part some of the animation is nice
but yeah that's about it Todd and copper
suddenly see that the CG circus is in
town why is the CG there's no reason
it's just a little cheaper and yeah
that's just kind of how this movie works
copper sees that there's a band called
the singing strays and he decides he
wants to join so he tries to sing and
they say hey you have a good voice and
seeing how our other thing or just left
you can join our band but the other
singer doesn't like that she was
replaced so quickly so she joins up with
Todd who wants to get his best friend
back and says hey why don't we try to
sabotage them so she shows that copper
is not really a stray hmm and suddenly
everything is thrown a wall and they'll
never be able to sing in the Grand Opera
and yeah what the hell does this have to
do with the original I'm not going to
act like the original was a classic but
by god it had some weight to it
it was about prejudice it was about
seeing past hatred it was about trying
to care for your fellow man told through
the story with a dog and a fox yeah I
know that sounds crazy but because they
really tried they tried to work with the
medium they had in the story they had
and they produce something that was
actually kind of decent this is crap
this is nicely animated actually too
well animated much better than the
original so it's kind of distracting how
well animated it is crap it's just a
knockoff a knockoff that's not really
trying I mean even the idea boxing the
hound
- I'm like Bambi - where there was this
large gap that could be filled in and
could be interesting Bambi with his
father what the hell can you do with Fox
and the Hound - I mean yeah there is
this gap but what's there to fill in
really nothing the two main characters
are separated so there's nothing that
fascinating you could put in there and
even if there was something best thing
to put in there this team wouldn't put
it in because it doesn't care okay
that's me and I shouldn't say that it
act like it doesn't care what we did as
a final product just feels like this
cheap corporate shell if your kids like
really bouncy imagery and some music and
just kind of pretty ish animation I mean
it's not really phenomenal but it's
better than average which again kind of
makes me feel bad because why are we
putting this good animation to this this
crappy story this is the Mulan - a fox
in the house sequels I know there's only
one box in the house sequel but yeah you
can see where I'm going in this
comparison its Mulan through all over
again except with a fox in the hound
it's this really decent but somehow
misguided animation that's not given the
proper direction there's not any
investment in the characters honestly
there's almost no reason to call it Fox
in the how this could be any characters
any characters could come across this
group of singing straight actually why
is it even a singing straight thing like
the crowd is watching saying wow it
almost sounds like those dogs are really
singing but they are really saying
that's really distracting would like the
owner be like holy
I have singing dogs I have to do
something with this but no does he think
if the records but they're really
singing it makes no sense but I don't
usually think about this but they try to
explain it and they suck at it like
everything in this movie sucks I was
trying to think if there was anything
anything in this film that was
redeemable and I guess I thought of one
and a half things
what is the animation yeah it is decent
the one full scene that I legitimately
like is when the owner of copper and the
owner of Todd are both looking for their
pets now these two don't like each other
but they cross paths and they
legitimately wish that the other find
their pets
that's a nice
that's something that actually would
have been nice to see in the original
it's heartwarming it's kind of decent
aside from that is cloth is pure 100%
blah and don't get me wrong if this
movie just wanted to be flop if it
wanted to be something on its own and
just say hey here's something for
two-year-olds like baby Einsteins except
without the education that'd be fine but
it's not it's the fox and the hound
- and when you have that title you have
to have something that at least is
trying to represent the original and
this one is in trying it has no interest
in being the original Fox and the hound
it just wants to make some fat money
look kind of cute and then disappear
well you know what you did you made some
fast money you look cute and you
disappeared look deep frigging do I
guess I can give it credit that just
like Mulan - it made me appreciate much
more what a good film the original was
now I appreciate what it was doing and
what a great work of prejudice destroy
art it was or maybe this one was just so
bad that I suddenly think it's a
masterpiece in comparison
let me either way I guess some good is
coming out of it I'm seeing some more
benefit out of the original Fox in the
islands that I did before but if you
want me to legitimately save boxing the
Hound to has something good to offer
I say woof
you
[Music]